all right let's do a lesson here in
dishonesty propaganda lying with
statistics a bunch of other stuff i have
a graphic that i'm going to show you
that i believe is at least a top
contender for the most dishonest graphic
ever shown on fox news and it's
dishonest probably in three
to four different ways okay
here's the graphic as you can see
it's from sean hannity's fox news
program last night this is really
instructive in terms of propaganda in
line with statistics
the graphic is part of a segment
wanting to blame joe biden for covet
deaths it was a segment about how bad
joe biden is
and of course the hypocrisy is
incredible
because these very same people didn't
really care about the covet death
numbers when donald trump was president
and in fact they went out of their way
to apologize for trump and claim he's
doing a great job and kovitz not that
serious and all of that stuff so the
claim here is is just comparing
covet deaths in 2020
to covet deaths in 2021 and making it
seem that joe biden is worse than trump
now what the graphic says or shows is
that in 2020
352 000 people died of covid
whereas in 2021
372 000 people died of covet so the
point here is 2020 under trump 352 000
kova deaths 2021
not even in the full year under biden
more deaths by about 20 000
so
let's consider the ways that this is
dishonest and i'm not doing this to
score points for one team or another
it's about understanding whether you are
being honestly given information and
what you should deduce from it so first
of all
uh donald trump was president
the first three weeks of 2021.
during those first three weeks of 2021
about 72 000 americans died of covet so
right off the bat
despite this graphic
of these deaths
424
000 happened when trump was president
and 300 000 happened while joe biden was
president so like without even debating
the merits of whether this entire
exercise makes any sense the
by president
donald trump actually was president
during 124 000 more coveted deaths than
joe biden this is actually pretty dumb
i'm not going to even say this is a this
is an intelligent thing to do there are
lots of people for example that died in
february when biden was president
but who caught the virus when trump was
president
who gets the blame for that death it's
sort of a weird metric it's not very
useful but by the standards of the
people making the graphics it could say
424 000 uh
dead under trump
300 000 dead under biden that paints a
completely different picture that's
layer of dishonesty number one
second layer of dishonesty the deaths
didn't really start in the united states
until april of 2020. okay
uh in the last 10 days of march 2020 we
saw deaths go up so even in comparing
these numbers and thinking about them as
trump versus biden
trump kind of had a freebie for january
of 2020 february of 2020 march most of
march of 2020. now some will say david
there were deaths in those months
we just didn't know that they were
covered yet they were called pneumonia
or something else that's right the point
is they're not in the numbers okay so in
the biden category they're including the
first three weeks of 2021 when biden
wasn't even president plus
more months overall since we have about
nine weeks left this year and trump
really only had eight months
worth of deaths in 2020 so that's
another level of dishonesty for what is
a very stupid exercise all right that's
another one
but now let me get to the really
dishonest part of this
the deaths even in 2021 even today
are mostly
overwhelmingly
the unvaccinated who are mostly
trump-supporting republicans so is it
really joe biden's fault
that trump supporters
have been bamboozled into not wanting
the vaccine by other right-wingers
and they are dying for me that's the
real dishonesty here and of course
there's this highly contagious delta
variant which plagued the planet in 2021
that's not trump's fault it's not joe
biden's fault although
more vaccination would have slowed down
the mutation as uh vincent racanello and
others have told us so a ton of this
stuff it's like it's kind of ticky tacky
as we might say in sports well there's
these three weeks and uh in january when
when trump was still president but
when do the deaths really become under
the watch of one president versus when
the deaths happen when the person got
sick it's tough it's nebulous it's not
particularly meaningful comparing 11
months for biden
to eight months for trump that's also
dishonest but the real dishonesty
is that they do all this stuff while
ignoring that the deaths are higher
because of right-wing anti-vaxxers and
it's more right-wingers than
left-wingers all along who were
participating in behaviors that spread
the virus and also this is a subtle
attack on vaccination we shouldn't
ignore that
we are far more vaccinated now than in
2020 and that was the theme yesterday on
fox news in part thanks to the death of
colin powell who as we already talked
about was fully vaccinated
but 84 years old
immunocompromised parkinson's cancer so
it's incredibly dishonest it's important
to spot the stuff and sometimes there's
kind of two analyses that need to be
done
one is we just look at the numbers and
we think through okay wait so
who was president in 2020 how many
deaths okay let's think about that when
did death start to even be counted in
2020 uh we we have to think about all
that but then there's the big dishonesty
which is the ways in which these numbers
are being used to make political
statements that don't actually follow
from the numbers and ignore who it is
that's keeping people from being
vaccinated in the first place so
up there up there one of the most
dishonest graphics i've seen on fox news
when you really break it down and think
it through